looking forward to one of these in
person for quite some time right thanks
come on cole down by 10 in the fourth
quarter
what did you guys do to come back and
win this game we fought man
shout out to the team man shout out to
rj shout out to dell
shout out to mo bamba shout out to my
whole team man you know we had to go get
that dub man
shout out to the magi man let's go how
about you call you took over in that
fourth quarter you're very comfortable
with the basketball made some big shots
how were you able to get it going in the
fourth and look bro just big shout out
to my team man they [ __ ] up
everybody fought back they put me in a
situation where i was able to you know
take over the game oh man shout out to
rj gary they had a big title i almost
turned the ball over they got to pull
back gary got the ball passes rjr to hit
a big three
and we out of here man he hit a pull-up
jumper he had some great defensive plays
rj what what did you see what did rj
show you the definition of being ready
man you know he rj i've been talking he
been a little upset man just because he
you know him and playing the miss i
think he should be playing he thinks he
should be playing and you know he just
stayed ready man so big shout out to my
boy roderick that's a real name for you
y'all don't know roderick i ain't got to
say it but you know he came in ready and
you know he helped us get that done man
it's big time right there donovan
mitchell tried to assert himself at the
end as well how are you guys able to
keep him at bay defensively oh man rj
just you know he really stepped up
defensively and really you know him and
gary i think all of us i mean kind of
when it came to crush time we all kind
of locked in defensively and you know
we won the game you guys felt the crowd
very good team in utah here tonight how
much did they help here tonight colt who
the crowd hey man i'm glad we got all
these magic fans right here man shout
out to all these magic fans man shout
out to all the magic fans man i know it
ain't been the best start man but you
know they sticking with us man the real
fans is here i know i know the arena is
packed we want it to be but okay well
it's coming with performances like this
you keep winning man the serena will
start packing up man last thing you're
at the free throw line and i know you
heard the mvp chance i know that must
have been fun for me i i started saying
stop it a little bit because i don't
feel like i deserve that yet when i
deserve that john i want this whole
crowd to be saying that stuff all right
all right well you enjoyed this one here
tonight right i know you enjoyed that
goal yup yup yup fantastic cole anthony
with a big performance here tonight
and the magic grab a win
fun night here at amway center
never dull and totally unpredictable
post-game interview with dante
marchetelli another
gem for dante and cole anthony